[Music]
Pope Francis has been in the news lately
for been doing picking up the phone and
just cold calling
dozens of random people who've sent
letters to him and what he does is he
cold calls them and he offers words of
encouragement about their lives this is
true for example he gave advice to a
teenager who was worried about finding a
job just called the teenager up and just
last week the Pope called a pregnant
woman who found out her boyfriend
already had a wife and kid he calls her
up and offered to personally baptize her
baby yeah that's what he's been doing
and guess what he is still at it check
out the Pope's public remarks from
yesterday
Kapila party my pew la guerra wanted a
vast as EO knee
quanto Delory a poor tato a porta russo
delhi army Finn Polmar Tory Otto pays
no-name la cultura de los contro la
cultura del conflict Oh quelle a que
construye combi Vania Nepali a typo
Chioda Chioda do yankonju DC o de la
storia suelen austria Jionni a Kui no
suppose future
[Applause]